hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and I am Jerry
and we're gonna watch the trailer for
The Sims 4 I believe is what it is
III trailer that just came out for it
I'm excited to watch this because I love
The Sims haven't played it in like ten
years but I really loved it remember we
were addicted to the Sims yeah I really
liked the like The Sims
I haven't played The Sims 2 and on I
don't know there was something with that
like the big shift in like the animation
style that kind of bugged me but yeah I
know I used to love The Sims no not the
Sims is like oh yes like you would just
Sims a rollercoaster tycoon was a - you
wouldn't flirt all the time yeah you
would get married you have my head take
the doors out of their house and then
they would die you would shower and then
you would try to zoom in to see if you
got any tits or dick or acid action you
know I'm talking about come on you tried
it once or twice
probably yeah don't be so fun to play
sims online do it you can game I think
so are you gonna just play second life
yes he's cute dude this looks fun that
Barack Obama in the back that's Barack
it's like sins in the future interesting
cool like stories and stuff yeah okay
there's always vaguely I mean there was
always a vague story element because you
could have like ooh there's this sim
down the street let's have a party and
see if we can make them talk and then go
on dates and [ __ ] I got a mess a pretty
boring trailer it's just I it's nothing
well how do you show a trailer for The
Sims because it's like it's not like
metal gear isn't like that words like
here's the story it's like the story is
whatever you make it just reiterated
what the sentence is but that's the only
thing you can do with the Sims is like
you can update the packaging guys
defensive for the Sims I love it that's
the only thing you could do with this
Sims the whole point is making
characters and then having them like do
life things and like there's only so
much you can do with that good I've done
a little better
they added a Venus flytrap cow plant and
the spaceship and a spaceship they've
gone more fantasy with it I mean that's
sure like what else can you do what
you've said have you just could have
made a better trailer as what I'm saying
not like call their ad T not it doesn't
look that it looks like a it looks like
this it looks like the [ __ ] city it
looks exactly the same thing but I'm
like a different ed what there is
doesn't look like there's much different
to offer this seems like the whole like
ambitions you've always been able to
bang you know la and really like seat
like a so I mean look at a hardcore
realistic their interpretation domestic
violence you know fun [ __ ] maybe you
should play second life maybe second
life has that there's a game called
second life that has that kind of stuff
yeah people get like obsessed looks like
online and and and some people live
their lives in second life because you
can make your second life whatever you
want it to be how cool it was like I'm
joining that cold I still want to play
The Sims again I think if you find a
play online like would it mean like a
cute girl like she ends up being cute I
mean if that's how the scenario works
out then then cool that would be fun I
mean those are met as Sims we married in
The Sims if maybe that's a new a new
idea you should make like a dating site
that also has like a sims s kinter
active game so that you can play
together and then also maybe find it of
a match in meet in real life this is
what the Sims movie should be it's like
you've got mail but with Sims could
literally be any movie no but that's
something talking about make it a
beginning was to make it be a standout
Sims movie if they communicate through
the sins I mean I guess but it wouldn't
be it wouldn't be a Sims movie well your
yeah is your your look though I have
water in the game so a hyper meta
because then like yeah you would have to
find out halfway through the movie that
your protagonists who have been playing
The Sims are also being controlled by
somebody I know a computer man in the
sky when I'm making new ins of dollars
off the Sims movie and you're not
getting any of it you're gonna feel like
a super loser the point Sims is that
it's like it's like life but your god I
know but then it's like you tell it all
through the videogame you use the actual
video game so it's like watching your
friend play the sim it's like watching a
game like watching those videos or like
before talking over it and stuff where
you've seen it from two different points
of view so it's watching your friend
play The Sims yeah you're gonna go over
the show on high man you watch like I am
actually of the Sims
just project someone playing The Sims
and then they mean in real life I guess
but then it's not a Sims movie any movie
that heavily based on this sentence okay
like chef uses Twitter a lot that movie
uses twitter is like a plot device but
it's not the Twitter movie this would be
the same kind of thing but with the Sims
like it would be the Sims mine I'll can
the idea alright I did you go if you if
you can make that profitable than that
more power I just thought after reading
save the cat log line here we go after
two people meet online playing The Sims
things start to get complicated when
they mean in real life yeah but then
it's a romantic it's just any romantic
comedy but we have also feature people
who like this and it's it's based around
the Sims fine it shouldn't be called The
Sims it's like how do you make a cinema
because it's just about life it's like
I'm gonna make the game of life the
movie
half of movies that's more than half of
movies well barring like crazy up there
fiction whatever if you're near the
[ __ ] channel subscribe sorry Stephen
and no antagonist though your name cut
off Augustus he said it on the Godzilla
spoiler review poor Ryan he's like shut
it I want to tell sex jokes haha I was
barely talking during the Godzilla
spoiler review and a few people really
noticed bTW loved the show guys just
came across the last week and seemed
probably thirty vids since then this was
on May 19th he's probably seen 150 so
far keep me laughing please shout out
well my friend I notice you're bald are
you bald down there - hey it's good to
see you
what are you a queen what are you doing
with this why that's not my [ __ ] homo
yo whatever I don't know I just it's
kind of random see like conversations
like this should be in The Sims movie no
conversations that are like smoking
about up Giga pilot like flirt flirt
Erik Rada
Erik rata jdg 2 2 0 4 2 0 0 1 2004 2001
what's up ride guy gets the last word a
shout-out from you the next time Sally
joins you so I can get one from her - ha
Sally's not here just Jerry you if you
want a shout-out from me what's up JD g
2004 2001 going back in time thrown back
in time to eat [ __ ] you're like [ __ ]
Guy Pearce over here yeah yeah and
you're gonna go meet Jeremy Irons
dressed in blue we hear time travel
people really think not not Doc Brown
not Wolverine in x-men Days of Future
past no guy Pierce in a time machine and
remaking the guy Pierson Orlando Jones
in Orlando's life all agree yeah anyway
yeah I guess you remind us of Orlando
Jones
Sylvia Lopez she said on my x-men days
of future past review she said this is
an x-men
no class review it was funny because
nothing but sex jokes the whole time my
x-men Days of Future past them useful
and nothing but sex jokes that's what
makes it funny she was like he's got no
class Sylvia Lopez I don't care that's
not a compliment I don't care she's
probably cute her name's Sylvia Lopez
probably some hot latina she and Astra
Shanna
but I felt this was one that was well
earned it seems like it seems like the
opposite of wanting a shout-out no this
is funny man she's like a frequent
comment er okay just given this one is
it as a capsule first my Sims review I'm
just I would love to make now let's make
yourself this Sylvia Lopez comment Jesus
Jerry I'm sorry JJ Abrams Star Trek with
puppets I mean Star Wars with puppets
when he's using puppets
instead of CG they made a video from the
set of Star Wars where JJ Abrams is
talking about it and then a guy walks by
looks like an actual creature puppet
mm-hm and everyone freaked out cuz
they're like oh they're gonna actually
have creature puppets and not just you
know oh that sounds cool yeah well
Sylvia there's some fun facts for you I
probably at the door